we are in contact in constant contact
with the uh
this nuclear power plant and in general
with the ukrainian regulators and um the
entire nuclear community with large in
that country
when it comes to this facility as you
know and
most of your audience i think
to as well in the course of the night um
there was a hit of a
projectile on
one uh building
an administrative building is a training
center actually which is located within
the site of the nuclear power plant um
in uh saborozzi where um
no less than six reactors are located
no reactor was um uh affected by this uh
luckily but uh a fire ensued in this
administrative building which is
adjacent if you want a few hundred
meters uh from the the actual uh
reactors
and then after some um efforts the the
fire brigade of the plant was able was
able to put it down
um
needless to say
the uh
the compromise of the
integrity the physical integrity of a
nuclear power plant is a very very
serious thing
because you could have a more complex a
far more complicated scenario um in case
of uh
a a target or a nuclear reactor being
targeted and affected with possibilities
of a nuclear accident and releases of
radioactive material this is what not
what happened but
um
emphasizes the
unprecedented nature of what we are
seeing because we are seeing military
operations in a country that has a very
important very large
nuclear sector with 15 reactors over
in located in four
sites and many more facilities dealing
with the nuclear fuel cycle laboratories
waste storage ponds and facilities so uh
to have these operations uh this use of
force and exchange of fire in the
vicinity of these places is extremely uh
dangerous we are of course in contact uh
with the ukrainians and this morning i
announced my
availability and my disposition to
travel immediately to
ukraine
in consultation of course with the
ukrainian authorities and also with the
russian forces because it is a fact of
life that they are there uh to try to
have a stronger framework to protect the
safety and the security of these
facilities the one that was tricked and
the other ones
and and obviously the ukrainians would
welcome your intervention but have you
had any response from the russian
authorities yet for your offer
both sides are considering it as you can
imagine apart from the substance and the
nuclear safety and security specific
issues that are related what are we
going to be looking at
after what are the kinds of things that
should be done what are the commitments
that we had to ensure that is a
logistical aspect because this is a zone
of conflict
and of course in in disputed areas so
one should look at that as well but of
course that doesn't deter me that
doesn't deter the iaea from uh providing
uh
assistance you know i believe that
assistance is more than making speeches
or shooting tweet tweeters so uh we have
to
assist and we have to help when the
going gets rough and this is
what we are intending to do at this
moment
and
and what do you know about who is in
control of ukrainians still in actual
control of the running of the power
station as far as you're aware
in this case there is a peculiar i would
say situation because the
nuclear power
plant and the reactors and the
installations as such
are run
by the uh
by the local staff by the people who
normally
run
the operation
here and in chernobyl and in the others
as well but in this case in this
particular case
and also in the case of chernobyl
the russian forces have taken command of
the place which doesn't mean they are
manning they are
running the operation but they are in
charge they are controlling the access
they are securing the the place
basically they are in charge but when it
comes to the operations it's still the
ukrainians this is why i say it is a
very uh tense sort of situation and one
that certainly cannot last for too long
okay oh it certainly is tense rafael
mariano grossi really good to talk to
you thank you very much for giving your
time to sky news today